[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Dunja Hayali
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend was interessiert
mich der Putsch in Niger mag der ein
oder andere gedacht haben als heute
bekannt wurde dass das Militär einen
startstreich ausgeführt und den
Staatschef abgesetzt hat relevant ist
das Land aber unter anderem deshalb weil
über den die Bundeswehrsoldaten
aus Mali abgezogen werden sollten weil
der Niger nach militärputschen in
Burkina Faso und Mali das letzte Land in
der Sahelzone war das von einer
demokratisch gewählten Regierung geführt
und vom Westen gerne als Letzter Anker
der Stabilität gesehen wurde offenbar
war man vor lauter Hoffnung aber blind
auf mindestens einem Auge denn es ist
nicht der erste Versuch den Präsidenten
zu stürzen von stabil kann da also
wirklich nicht die Rede sein eine
gedreht Ostern
russische Flaggen in nyamei der
Hauptstadt von Niger nur einen Tag nach
dem Putsch protestierten gestern noch
die Anhänger des abgesetzten Präsidenten
basum prägen heute die Unterstützer der
militärputschisten das Bild
wir brauchen einen gleichberechtigten
Partner keinen mit dem nur der Westen
profitiert es geht um würde
gestern am späten Abend Statement der
Putschisten alle Institutionen der
Republik sind suspendiert die
verteidigungs- und Sicherheitskräfte
haben die Leitung übernommen und alle
externen Partner werden gebeten sich
nicht einzumischen
der Putsch im Ferne Niger trifft
Deutschland und auch die EU hart und
ganz direkt und das längst nicht nur
weil vom Luftwaffen Stützpunkt dort die
Bundeswehr ihren Abzug aus dem
benachbarten Mali
organisiertgrenze das Land ist die
Hauptroute Richtung Mittelmeer und
Migranten und wenn dort jetzt
Instabilität dauerhaft bleibt dann wird
es zu nehmen Migration kommen die der
Putsch könnte auch Russland die Tür
öffnen sich auch mega auszubreiten je
mehr Instabilität in Niger das so
schlechter für Europa
Niger war die letzte Hoffnung
Deutschlands und anderer ausländischer
Staaten in der Region wenigstens noch
einen Kooperationspartner zu haben erst
vor gut drei Monaten war
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius in Niger
und versprach die niedrigen Streitkräfte
so auszubilden über die nächsten Jahre
dass sie ihrem Auftrag Kampf gegen
Terrorismus und äußere Bedrohung noch
besser gerecht werden können als sie es
heute schon sind weil die Region einen
stabil einen stabilen Anker unbedingt
braucht und den sehen wir wie viele
andere Partner auch
dieser stabile Anker ist jetzt erstmal
weg gut 72 Millionen Euro wollte die EU
ab Oktober 22 für die kommenden zwei
Jahre in nieder investieren ich denke
Deutschland hat und Europa haben so ein
bisschen zu viel von nie gehabt nie
gegessen sehr warmes immer instabiles
Land gewesen und wir haben da so ein
bisschen geglaubt als Stabilitätsanker
können wir da eine Schweiz auch Bauen
von Stabilität könnte Niger derzeit kaum
weiter entfernt sein
was keine gute Nachricht für den besten
ist sowohl im Kampf gegen den
islamistischen Terrorismus als auch im
Ringen um weniger Migration wir haben es
gerade gehört und was mit einem vom
Militär geputschten Land passieren kann
kann man in den beiden Nachbarländern
beobachten in Burkina Faso und Mali
haben sich nämlich die neuen Machthaber
von westlichen Staaten abgewandt und
ihre Beziehungen zu Russland verstärkt
was mit mega passiert kann natürlich
heute noch keine abschätzen aber
Russland wird auch dort versuchen seine
Beziehungen auszubauen mehr Einfluss
mehr Partner mehr Abhängigkeiten
schaffen seit dem Angriffskrieg gegen
die Ukraine ist das das verstärkte Ziel
Putins und genau darum geht es auch auf
dem Afrika russland-gipfel in St
Petersburg der heute begonnen hat Putin
dürfte allerdings etwas enttäuscht sein
denn dieses Mal nehmen nur 17
Staatschefs Teil 2019 waren es noch 45
eventuell haben diese nicht vergessen
das Putin Kiew genau in dem Moment
beschießen ließ als mehrere afrikanische
Präsidenten dort waren um eine
Friedensmission zwischen der Ukraine und
Russland anzuschieben aber was ist die
Mission der Afrikaner jetzt was wollen
sie von Putin
Brote ein Grundnahrungsmittel in Kenia
Putins Entscheidung das getreideabkommen
mit der Ukraine aufzukündigen hier in
Nairobi hat es direkte Auswirkungen auf
die Menschen die schon unter hoher
Inflation und niedrigen Einkommen leiten
manchmal bekommen wir gar kein Mehl mehr
dann heißt es sei kein Weizen mehr da
und wer noch Weizen hat der verkauft die
natürlich sehr teuer
geplagten Horn von Afrika große Mengen
an Weizen und zwar bezahlbar genau das
blockiert Putin der Unmut nicht nur in
Kenia ist groß Nairobi schickte nur
einen Botschafter zum Gipfel und
bedauert sehr dass Afrika dort nicht mit
einer Stimme auftritt
viele afrikanische Staaten haben nun
einmal langjährige Beziehungen zu
Russland vor allem militärische und für
diese Länder ist der ukraine-konflikt
einfach sehr weit weg
Konflikt auf diese engen Bindungen setzt
Putin auf Diktatoren wie Isaias Affe
werki aus Eritrea Militär Herrscher wie
Ägyptens als CC auf Putschisten aus
Burkina Faso die sich mit Hilfe
russischer Wagner Söldner an der Macht
halten trotzdem musste sich Putin heute
deutlicher Kritik anhören
Russland ist ein strategischer Partner
30% der afrikanischen weizenimporte
kommen aus Russland aber wir brauchen
Getreide aus Russland und der Ukraine
deshalb muss dringend ein Abkommen her
Entwicklung
besonders beeindruckt zeigte sich Putin
nicht auch weil keiner der
Gipfel-Teilnehmer es sich leisten kann
Russland klar als kriegsergressor zu
bezeichnen ähnlich vorsichtig auch die
Kritik des un-chefs in New York der Ross
und Reiter auch nicht nennen darf
es wurde ja nicht nur das
getreideabkommen aufgekündigt es werden
auch systematisch ernteeinrichtungen und
Getreidesilos bombardiert das ist eine
ernste Eskalation
Putin nutzt die gipfelbühne für seine
Propaganda Bomben auf Getreidespeicher
Abkommen torpediert alles Schuld des
Westens so seine Botschaft an die
afrikanischen Freunde garniert mit einem
großzügigen Angebot
Russland kann ukrainisches Getreide
durch russisches ersetzen wir werden
besonders Bedürftigen Ländern wie Mali
Burkina Faso Eritrea Somalia bis zu
30.000 Tonnen kostenlos bereitstellen
mit der Ukraine jedenfalls das macht der
Protein klar wird es nicht geben
Russland Afrika Gipfel während in Niger
ein Putsch stattfindet die Parallelität
der Ereignisse ist wohl eher ein Zufall
wird aber von Experten und Expertinnen
sehr genau beobachtet so wie auch von
Julia Grauvogel sie ist Sprecherin des
Forschungsteams Intervention und
Sicherheit am Leibniz-Institut für
globale und regionale Studien in Hamburg
und damit einen schönen guten Abend
guten Abend wie ist ihre Einschätzung
braucht Afrika die Hilfe Russlands oder
ist es doch eher andersrum
Russland braucht auf jeden Fall Afrika
und verfolgt in Afrika verschiedene
wirtschaftliche und geostrategische
Interessen da geht es natürlich um
Rohstoffe und insbesondere Gold im
Austausch für Waffenlieferungen ist noch
wichtiger geworden seit Russland mit
massiven Finanzsanktionen des Westens
konfrontiert ist weil eben das russische
Gold anders als die ausländischen
Devisen nicht einfach eingefroren werden
kann Russland möchte aber auch mit
diesem Gipfel das Bild transportieren
das ist international nicht so isoliert
ist wie der Westen das versucht
darzustellen afrika braucht aber auch
Russland afrika braucht Russland vor
allem als Waffenlieferant mittlerweile
kommt fast die Hälfte aller Waffen aus
auf dem afrikanischen Kontinent aus
Russland und afrika braucht Russland
auch um sich als unabhängige Akteur in
der internationalen Politik darzustellen
denn nicht nur vom Westen abhängig ist
und was Afrika unter Umständen auch
braucht ist ja Getreide jetzt hat Putin
zum Auftakt es Gipfel sechs
afrikanischen Staaten kostenlose
Getreide Lieferungen versprochen wird
dass das ver hältnis dann sagen wir mal
verbessern verstärken
ja mit diesem Versprechen rennt Putin
anders als früher nicht mehr unbedingt
offene Türen ein das Ende oder das
vorläufige Ende des getreideabkommens
ist von vielen afrikanischen Staaten
sehr stark kritisiert worden russland
hat zwar versucht zum Teil sogar durch
Zeitungsartikel von offiziellen in
lokalen Zeitungen beispielsweise in
Kenia den besten die Schuld zuzuschieben
aber es ist so dass dieser russische
Schritt in Afrika massiv kritisiert
wurde und das jetzt erstmal darauf
gewartet wird wie genau diese
Versprechen umgesetzt werden bevor das
vielleicht zu einer wiederernährung
führt bei dem Gipfel jetzt in St
Petersburg soll auch Partnerschaft
prigoshi dabei sein seine Truppen
spielen ja in diversen afrikanischen
Ländern eine große Rolle sie wollten
beispielsweise Goldminen und Diamanten
vorkommen aus Stützen Diktatoren und
unterdrücken Demokraten wie reagieren
denn die afrikanischen Staaten darauf
also wie sehen sie diese Einflussnahme
ja einige afrikanische Staaten sind
natürlich sehr eng verbunden mit den
Wagner Söldnern und da gab es auch eine
gewisse Unsicherheit wie es nach der
gescheiterten Revolte weitergeht und
gewissermaßen sogar ein Interesse daran
dass Russland bekräftigt hat dass man
das militärische Engagement auf dem
Kontinent fortsetzen wird es gab
zunächst Überlegungen ob man die
wagnertruppen zum Teil wieder durch
russische Offiziere austauscht das
scheint nicht der Fall zu sein aber
grundsätzlich ist es so dass zumindest
in einzelnen Staaten der
Zentralafrikanische Republik auch in
Mali eher Interesse daran besteht dass
dieses russische Engagement fortgesetzt
wird und zeitgleich zum Gipfel ich habe
schon angesprochen hat ja auch der
Putsch jetzt in Niger stattgefunden was
bedeutet dieser Staatsstreich für die
Sicherheit in der Region und aber auch
für die Hoffnungen der EU
ja es ist wichtig zunächst einmal zu
betonen dass das kein Pro russischer
Putsch war sondern es hängt ganz
entscheidend zusammen mit Konflikten
innerhalb des Regimes mit Konflikten
innerhalb der Armee nichtsdestotrotz
bricht damit natürlich ein Land zusammen
oder bricht ein vermeintlicher
Stabilitätsanker wie verschiedene
Mitglieder der Bundesregierung das immer
wieder benannt haben wird unstabiler und
das ist natürlich ein ein gravierendes
Problem für Europa auch weil in der
Region Alternativen fehlen der Rückzug
aus Mali soll stattfinden Frankreich
zieht sich auch aus Burkina Faso zurück
der Chat ist eine der fragilsten Länder
der Welt das heißt es ist nicht nur eine
gewisse Naivität dass man nicht also als
Stabilitätsanker bezeichnet hat sondern
ganz stark auch ein Mangel an
Alternativen in der Region
Frau Vogel vielen herzlichen Dank für
das Gespräch heute und ihnen alles Gute
sehr gerne
und das Gespräch haben wir heute um 20
Uhr aufgezeichnet der Putsch er könnte
den Abzug der deutschen Bundeswehr aus
Mali über den Niger verkomplizieren
eventuell braucht es da jetzt also einen
Plan B mehr dazu auch im heute-journal
Update gegen 0 Uhr 30 mit dem
Sicherheitsexperten Nico lange und wir
machen jetzt hier weiter mit Nachrichten
und Gundula wenn man so will mit
Statistiken ja dieser juli wird nach
UN-Angaben der bislang heißeste Monat
seit
Aufzeichnungsbeginn sein darauf lassen
Daten des europäischen
klimawandel-dienstes Kopernikus
schließen die globale
Durchschnittstemperatur liegt demnach in
diesem Juli so hoch wie noch nie
in den brandgebieten Griechenlands hat
die Hitze nachgelassen auf etwa 35 Grad
mittlerweile sind die Feuer größtenteils
unter Kontrolle wegen starke Winde aber
bleibt die Brandgefahr groß im
Landesinnern wurden zwei weitere
Todesfälle in Folge der Feuer bekannt
das ukrainische Parlament hat das
Kriegsrecht und die angeordnete
Mobilmachung um weitere 90 Tage
verlängert beide Maßnahmen gelten nun
bis Mitte November unterdessen hat
Russland die Ukraine in einer neuen
Angriffswelle mit dutzenden Raketen und
Kampfdrohnen attackiert nach Angaben der
ukrainischen Luftwaffe sind Geschosse in
der Nähe eines
Militärflughafens in der Westukraine
abgefangen worden sowie in den Gebieten
Kiew karkiff und nibro auch die
Hafenstadt Odessa war wieder Ziel
russischer Angriffe
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Habeck will
die Strom- und gaspreisbremsen bis
Ostern 2024 verlängern angesichts
gesunkener Einkaufspreise seien die
energiepreisbremsen vor allem eine
Vorsichtsmaßnahme über die es bereits
Gespräche mit der EU gebe nach jetzigem
Stand würden die preisbremsen zum
Jahresende auslaufen der grünen
Politiker hat erneut einen schnelleren
Ausbau zusätzlicher Stromnetze gefordert
das sei einer der zentralen Faktoren für
das Gelingen der Energiewende sagte er
in baden-württembergischen Leingarten
beim Startschuss für den Bau des ersten
von vier Konvertern diese sind in der
geplanten
nord-süd-stromtrasse südlink notwendig
um die strohmmengen zu erhalten die
Trasse südlink soll bis 2028
fertiggestellt sein sechs Jahre später
als geplant habe ich sagte der lange
Vorlauf
inakzeptabel
jetzt geht der Blick weg von der
Stromtrasse hin zur Fahrrinne das Schiff
das gestern in der Nähe der Insel
Ameland Feuer gefangen hat konnte heute
stabil von der Fahrrinne ferngehalten
werden so dass andere Schiffe passieren
können zudem ist es stand heute nicht
gesunken soweit erst einmal die guten
Nachrichten die er nicht so guten
Nachrichten das Schiff brennt weiter und
die Kühlung durch Wasser musste
eingestellt werden der Frachter war ja
unterwegs aus Bremerhaven nach Ägypten
der Großbrand war dann gestern 27 km
nördlich der niederländischen
Wattenmeerinsel Ameland ausgebrochen das
Schiff liegt nun etwa 16 km nördlich der
Insel Terschelling Günther
neue Bilder von der Free mental Highway
raucht wild vom Oberdeck zieht weit über
die größte Schifffahrtsstraße in der
Nordsee die Küstenwache redet gestern
per Funk über die Brandursache das
Gespräch wird abgehört
es fing an in der Batterie eines
Elektroautos 25 sind ein Bord eins ist
wohl explodiert
der Akku eines E-Autos kann durch
Fabrikationsfehler oder bei einem Unfall
in Brand geraten er besteht aus vielen
Modulen in denen sich einzelne
Batteriezellen befinden wenn eine davon
einen Defekt hat kann sie sich stark
erwärmen es entstehen entzündliche Gase
so kann in einer Kettenreaktion ein
Brand entstehen der von außen mit
Löschwasser schlecht zu erreichen ist
deshalb muss der Akku in einem Wasserbad
lange gekühlt werden
Lars Tober Schuld Schiffsbesatzungen im
Kampf gegen Feuer mehr E-Autos als
Fracht das verlange neue Löschanlagen da
muss man sich nochmal einen Kopf machen
die ich auch Kühlung in das Schiff
bekomme weil zur Zeit wird mit CO2 oder
ultraleicht-schrauben gelöscht und dass
der Kühleffekt also zu vernachlässigen
und da muss dran gearbeitet werden
die Akkus der E-Autos seien nur ein
Risiko im Vergleich zu diesem
Übungsobjekt stecke heute mehr Plastik
mehr Brandlast in allen Autos natürlich
auch in Tanks
Betriebsstoffe brennen also Diesel
Benzin dann reden wir schon von 8 900
Grad und das kommt dann natürlich auch
schon an die strukturgrenze von Stahl
das ist das Problem noch blättert nur
die Farbe die Außenhaut hält zu viel
kühlwasserbrechte mehr Schlagseite es
ist das Dilemma der Retter letztes Jahr
brannte im Atlantik bereits ein anderer
autofrachter auch damals galt ein E-Auto
als Ursache und jetzt auch noch dieses
Schiff das zeigt es gibt Vorschriften
für den Transport von Elektroautos aber
die reichen wohl nicht aus
dieser Brand so sagen selbst die Räder
müssen ein Weckruf sein
ja vielleicht auch weil sich unter
anderem 1600 Tonnen Schweröl sowie
weitere 200 Tonnen Marine diese auf
diesem Schiff befinden und ein Sinken
das Frachters wäre natürlich eine
Umweltkatastrophe für den Nationalpark
Watten mehr und für das Ökosystem in der
Nordsee ganz generell Isabell Schäfers
ist für uns weiterhin in der Nähe der
Unglückstelle vielleicht zunächst mal
die Frage nach der Stabilität des
Schiffes wie sieht's da aus
also der Frachter brennt weiterhin und
es ist auch weiterhin so heiß an Bord
dass niemand dort auf an Bord gehen kann
und es musste auch die Kühlung
eingestellt werden weil eben zu viel
Wasser an Bord ein Kentern verursacht
hätte hätte können und deshalb
konzentriert man sich jetzt hier vor Ort
vor allem auf das stabilisieren das
Schiffes mit Hilfe eines
schlepperschiffes was mit dem brennenden
Frachter verbunden ist und soweit wir
hören funktioniert das auch sehr gut die
Situation sei stabil wurde uns hier
gesagt und der Frachter kann sich weiter
bewegen auch aufgrund der Strömung und
der Winde ist er heute erst etwas in
Richtung Westen und jetzt wohl wieder
leicht in Richtung Osten gedriftet aber
wohl alles sehr kontrolliert so
kontrolliert das auch die Fahrerin
weiter frei bleiben und der weitere
Schiff Verkehr ganz normal laufen konnte
das klingt ja erstmal ganz gut aber
Stichwort Umweltkatastrophe vielleicht
auch da noch mal nachgefragt wie
bereitet man sich dort auf solch eine
Situation vor
ja also das Risiko ist natürlich nicht
komplett gebannt dass das Schiff noch
sinken könnte oder brechen könnte und
deshalb neben allem was man hier so tut
bereitet man sich auch im Hintergrund
schon eben auf diesen schlimmsten Fall
vor vor Ort an in der Nähe des Frachters
ist bereits ein Spezialschiff was darauf
spezialisiert ist Öl aufzufangen sollte
das doch austreten und auch hier auf
Ameland an Land sagte mir der
Bürgermeister werden die Einsatzkräfte
bereits darauf vorbereitet doch schnell
auch einzugreifen sollte hier doch Öl
und anderes Material an Land kommen aber
trotzdem ist natürlich die Priorität
weiterhin das Schiff am Sinken zu
hindern und da gibt es eigentlich
weiterhin zwei Optionen dass man eben
doch noch das Feuer so weit löschen kann
dass das Schiff abgeschleppt werden kann
oder sonst eben dass man auf dem Meer
das Schiff komplett ausbrennen lässt und
auf diese beiden Optionen setzt man
bisher noch Isabel Schäfers war das
vielen Dank für die Schilderung
und wir machen jetzt hier weiter mit
Nachrichten aus der Wirtschaft Gundula
im Kampf gegen die hohe Inflation hat
die Europäische Zentralbank die
Leitzinsen ein weiteres Mal angehoben
wieder um einen viertel Prozentpunkt auf
nun
4,25%. das war so an den Finanzmärkten
erwartet worden Stefanie berrett ist das
nun der zinsgipfel oder wird es weitere
Schritte geben also sagen wir es so der
zinsgipfel ist in Sicht denn die
Geldpolitik beginnt nach insgesamt 9
Erhöhungen in nur einem Jahr zu wirken
die Inflation in der Eurozone hat sich
seit ihrem Höchststand im Oktober
vorigen Jahres nahezu halbiert mit
fünfeinhalb Prozent ist sie aber immer
noch weit entfernt vom Idealmaß von zwei
Prozent deshalb ließ ezb-präsidentin
Lagarde heute in Frankfurt die
Entscheidung noch offen ob sie im
September ein weiteres Mal die Zinsen
erhöht eine Pause schloss sie aber auch
nicht aus entscheiden will sie allein
auf Grundlage der Wirtschaftsentwicklung
und da deuten ja einige Daten auf eine
Rezession hin wie schätzen das aktuell
Ökonomen ein ja da mehren sich durchaus
stimmen die befürchten die EZB könnte
mit ihren Erhöhungen auch übers Ziel
hinausschießen interessanterweise
plädieren aber weite Teile der
Wirtschaft sogar die Bauwirtschaft die
ja schwer betroffen ist eher für eine
konsequente Bekämpfung der Inflation
denn unter den hohen Preisen leiden eben
alle sowohl Verbraucher als auch Firmen
außerdem hadern deutsche Unternehmen
mehr bekanntlich noch mit ganz anderen
Problemen als mit steigenden Zinsen
Stefan vielen Dank
die Deutsche Bahn hat einen Zuwachs bei
den Fahrgästen und einen Einbruch beim
gewinnverzeichnet die Halbjahresbilanz
des bundeseigenen Konzerns zeigt einen
nachsteuerverlust von 71 Millionen Euro
wegen Kostensteigerungen und
Investitionen ins Schienennetz auch die
Pünktlichkeit der Fernzüge hat sich mit
einer Quote von
68,7% verschlechtert positiv hingegen im
Fernverkehr nutzten gut 15% mehr
Fahrgäste die Bahn als im
Vorjahreszeitraum
bei der Fußball-WM der Frauen müssen die
Titelverteidigerinnen aus den USA und
Gastgeber Australien überraschend ums
Weiterkommen zittern die Amerikanerinnen
holten gegen die Niederlande nur ein
eins zu eins Unentschieden und stehen im
nächsten Spiel gegen Portugal unter
Zugzwang die Portugiesinnen siegten
heute verdient gegen Vietnam 2:0 und die
Gastgeberinnen aus Australien verloren
überraschen gegen Nigeria 2 zu 3
eine Studie zufolge ziehen sich die
Deutschen mehr und mehr ins Private
zurück als Reaktion auf Krisen wie Krieg
und Klimawandel das Kölner
rheingold-institut erklärt auf Basis
einer repräsentativen Studie die meisten
Befragten klammerten die bedrohliche
Wirklichkeit aus und richteten den Fokus
auf ihre persönliche Lebenswelt ihre
private Zukunft sehen dem nach 87%
optimistisch das Vertrauen in die
Politik dagegen sei gering 77% erklärten
sie seien da pessimistisch
wenn wir über Luftangriffe während des
Zweiten Weltkriegs sprechen dann schauen
wir oft auf und nach Dresden sie fanden
aber auch anderswo statt so wie in
diesen Tagen vor 80 Jahren auf Hamburg
und sie lösten ein Inferno aus im
Feuersturm der Alliierten starben 10.000
Menschen ganze Stadtteile wurden völlig
zerstört unter dem sogenannten Codenamen
Operation Gomorra starteten Briten und
US-Amerikaner sogar eine ganze Reihe von
schweren Luftangriffen auf Hamburg mit
einem
unvorstellbaren Ausmaß und die Spuren
sie sind bis heute sichtbar der
Feuersturm für einige bis heute
unvergessen
wird dieser Bunker Karl-heinz Pischke
war zehn als der Bunker fertig wurde
mitten auf St Pauli dieses Jahr wird
Karl-heinz Pischke 90 auf Führungen
durch seinen Stadtteil erzählt er wie
das war im Zweiten Weltkrieg als
Alliierten Bombe Hamburg Angriffen und
er und seine Mutter zum ersten Mal in
den Bunker am heiligen geistfeld fliehen
mussten wir waren im Bunker drin war
einer halben Stunde da drin dann kam die
ersten Menschen also geschockt die
wussten nicht mehr einige die waren so
geschockt die hat nur im Bademantel
übergeworfen und vielleicht den
Vogelbauer in der Hand noch nicht mal
Wertsachen dabei und sind dann
reinkommen einige die sagten ja es
brennt über alles brennt überall
750 britische Bomber greifen in diesen
Nächten der Operation Feuersturm Hamburg
an es trifft in erster Linie die
Stadtteile mit vielen Arbeitern nach und
nach die Innenstadt und damit auch das
Wohnhaus von Karl-Heinz Pischke
die Tatsache war aber dann dass wir dann
da nicht mehr schlafen konnten für uns
war der nur noch der Bunker da sind wir
zum Bunker zurück und hatten nur das an
was wir hatten und haben uns dann auf
die Bank des haben wir genächtigt jetzt
bekommt er graue Riese ein grünes Dach
zugänglich für alle neben einem Hotel
wird es im Inneren Orte der Erinnerung
geben und er konnte ich genau den
Hamburger Michel sehen der war so
angeleuchtet und den umliegenden
brennenden Häusern die heute sozusagen
durch Scheinwerfer vielleicht
angestrahlt ne wie oft Karl-heinz
Pischke in den Bunker fliehen musste
weiß er nicht mehr das Gebäude hatte
Platz für 25000 Menschen eine
bedrückende Engel der grüne Aufbau mit
den fast 5000 Pflanzen für Karl-heinz
Pischke eine mehr als verdiente
Würdigung hier in diesem Fall wo
praktisch mir der Bunker das Leben
gerettet hat aber auch vielen anderen
das Leben gerettet hat finde ich das gut
dass man den Bunker jetzt nicht nur ein
Blumenstrauß gibt sondern dass man ihn
begrüßt im Spätherbst soll der große
Blumenstrauß auf dem Bunker fertig sein
in den Führungen durch seinen Stadtteil
schildert Karl-heinz Pischke ohne
Beschönigung wie es war viele Freunde
und Nachbarn zu verlieren ich denke so
dass der Schöpfer des Universums
die Menschen die durch diese sinnlosen
Kriege ums Leben gekommen sind dass er
sie umarmt und tröstet das hoffe ich
mehr als 40.000 Menschen starben in den
sieben Angriffswellen auf Hamburg die
Staat und Karl-Heinz Pirsch getrösten
sich mit einem grünen Dach auf dem
Bunker der Karl-heinz Pischke und vielen
anderen das Leben gerettet hat
[Musik]
faszinierende Persönlichkeit sind sie
vielleicht auch ein bisschen davon
genervt dass in unserem Land gefühlt
nichts geht Bildung Pflege
Digitalisierung Integration Energiewende
Mobilität alles hängt gefühlt irgendwie
fest aber lässt sich dieses Gefühl auch
belegen das wollte Christian Sievers
wissen und war wochenlang in Deutschland
unterwegs und erlebte vielerorts genau
das Stillstand ein Land im Stillstand im
Schritttempo geht es für Christian
überbrücken die nicht fertig werden und
deren Kosten explodieren
in deutschen Ämtern stapeln sich
weiterhin die Papierberge weil Anträge
von Studierenden zwar digital
eingereicht werden können aber
ausgedruckt werden müssen ja wie sind
wir da nur reingeraten und wie kommen
wir vor allen Dingen da wieder raus
ampuls mit Christian Sievers jetzt
direkt im Anschluss und jederzeit in der
ZDF-Mediathek und ich kann Ihnen
verraten christian hatte auch ein
bisschen Puls
die fehlt noch der Hinweis auf unser
heutejournal Update gegen 0:30 Uhr mit
Nasen also dann machen sie es gut wo
auch immer Sie sind und bitte dran
bleiben bis morgen
[Musik]
guten Abend jetzt wird der Regen wärmer
und das liegt an dieser südwestlichen
Strömung sehr eindrucksvoll ist auch
dieses Tief Ventur das morgen
Großbritannien erreicht viel
interessanter vielleicht ist die Hitze
am Mittelmeer und die lag ja auch heute
noch bei 40 bis 45 Grad und diese Hitze
wird jetzt in den nächsten zwei Tagen
sich doch mehr und mehr nach Osten
verabschieden jedenfalls mal
vorübergehend eine kleine Entwarnung in
Sachen Hitze ist das also heute Nacht
fällt bei uns weiterer Regen und der ist
zum Teil auch mit Gewittern durchsetzt
hier in Norddeutschland am ehesten
trocken ist es zwischen dem Allgäu und
dem Oberrhein der Winter kommt aus
südwestlichen Richtung und so wird diese
Nacht für einige vielleicht sogar schwül
erscheinen denn die Temperaturen bleiben
mild bei 17 bis 13 Grad am Alpenrand
sind es um die 11 Grad und morgen wird
es etwas wärmer als heute für die
meisten von uns 21 Grad sind es in der
westlichen Mittelgebirge und auch an den
Küsten von Nord und Ostsee bis zu 27
Grad in der Lausitz oder auch das Bayern
erstmal regnet es noch aber dann locker
die Regenwolken mehr und mehr auf und es
entwickeln sich Regenschauer und
Gewitter am ehesten trocken ist es an
der Küste und auch am alpenrad heute hat
sie schon kräftig geregnet in
Nordrhein-Westfalen zum Teil bis zu 35
Liter pro Quadratmeter innerhalb von 24
Stunden morgen wird das viel weniger
sein maximal so 5 bis 15 Liter pro
Quadratmeter erwarten werden 24 Stunden
wechselhaft geht's dann auch zum
Wochenende weiter der Freundliche Tag
wird eindeutig der Sonntag guten Abend